für mein empfinden mit große gewaltig
können das heißt es denn deutschland
gemeinsam machen es aber keinen satz
dieses gewusel macht mich
mein vater war bergmann
ist der präsident
laschet mit kohlestaub ich das ja zum
schießen unser ganzes land die pandemie
hat uns alle getroffen sie hat auch
gezeigt wie sehr wir an dem auftritt
strache der schönste die chance nutzen
deutschland zum wo das ist das bild des
fortschritts kabel leuchten lampen
haben jetzt nach vorne ja wer armin
laschet bild wählt internet deutschland
zu modernisieren
was ist die botschaft von armin laschet
will die skyline von frankfurt
ich stelle mich hats hetze und gewalt
entgegen und werde das auch als
bundeskanzler
erstaunlicherweise spricht laschet nicht
in die kamera
mein deutschland ist ein weltoffenes
land das sei in deutschland ganz mit
meinem deutschland das ist bisschen
konfus ich erfüllen kann wer sind diese
menschen wer soll sich angesprochen
fühlen
egal woher man kommt woran man glaubt
oder wen man liebt
hier weiß man nicht was einem sagen
denkt man weiß auch nicht wer der
adressat
des ganzen sports ist er versucht
irgendwie alles mit reinzubringen wir
sind uns einig wir müssen den
klimawandel kommt damit
katastrophenbilder
schützen
ich will dass deutschland industrieland
bleibt und mittendrin armin laschet wird
nicht wieder einem anderen
land der digitalen dichter und denker
das stelle ich mir unter einem modernen
deutschland vor ich bin armin laschet
digitale dichter und denker das finde
ich habe ich die alliteration ist
natürlich sehr glücklich
aber was genau ich mir darunter
vorstellen soll sind es menschen die
ja weiß ich jetzt auch nicht am computer
musik das
gesicht von armin laschet was einfach
auch mimisch kostet defensive nicht
herauskommt er wirkt so als hätte
irgendwer in beleidigt und jetzt wolle
er sich rechtfertigen
doch der ton um uns herum für trauer der
kurde starb im gesicht war glaube ich
vielleicht entweder nicht geplant oder
jedenfalls keine gute idee deutschland
gemeinsam machen ja was immer das auch
heißen sollen ich glaube es ist ein satz
sei dass sein deutschland gemeinsam
machen aber es für eine partei die sich
so auf die auf die fahnen schreibt dass
sie natürlich auch das deutsche die
deutsche sprache irgendwie hochhält
finde ich das eigentlich näher
beschissenes deutsch was heißt das denn
deutschland gemeinsam machen es aber
keinen satz und
da fühlt man sich am ende so fest umarmt
fest gedrückt
und weiß dass man dann auch
am ende des tages noch wenn man seine
zwei stimmen für die richtige partei
abgegeben hat dann kann man schön
entspannt in den sechsten gang schalten
und mit 250 sachen einfach mal den
ganzen stress sich von asylverfahren so
schön